bonjour antoine boitel vous avez traité
dans l'un de vos articles la baisse du
niveau des recrutements et des
formations dans la police pouvez vous
nous en dire plus mais bonjour alors les
nouvelles recrues de la police nationale
ne satisferait plus les critères
d'exigence d'autres fois c'est le pire
et rarement d'une enquête de cartes du
parisien qui nous a pas vraiment étonné
du fait des travaux on avait mené par
avant alors les formateurs et les
membres du jury qui ont été contactés
par le journal
il alerte également sur le niveau de
connaissance et d'expression des
candidats et deux stagiaires s'est jugée
trop faible notamment et
particulièrement en ile de france
c'est à des problèmes d'expression des
problèmes de doral parfois il s'énerve
quand il leur manque du coup ni
vocabulaire en ile de france en
particulier
alors il ya plusieurs régions qui sont
avancés des hypothèses
premièrement les candidats qui sont bien
notés au concours de police nationale
vont choisir une affectation qui va être
qui va les rapprocher dans domicile
familial origines m du coup il ya moins
d'un moins de policiers et de france qui
choisissent ils de france donc c'est les
moins bien notés qu'ils ont choisi de
france
d'autre part il ya un fort besoin autour
de paris parce que les fonctionnaires
qui sont parfois plus aguerris qui ont
déjà un peu de carrière quand il le peut
également se faire muter ailleurs selon
cette même quai mais ce besoin justement
sans cesse renouvelé de recruter en
ile-de-france bien parti ça pourrait
avoir engendré une baisse des critères
d'entrée au concours
par exemple les erreurs éliminatoires
qui avait été relevé auparavant c'est à
dire oublier une signature sur un pv de
piennes date sur un tv c'est plus
éliminatoires on va recruter des
candidats jusqu'à 7 ou 8 sur 20 ce qui
équivaut selon les formateurs interrogé
par le parisien un niveau plus ou moins
collège se voulait donc c'était quand
même problème c'est quand même
problématique cette situation actuelle
est en forme watchers il a surtout été
décidé de raccourcir les violences
formation de 12 mois à 8 mois le khalife
de l'actuel lycée intérieur géraldine
analyser cette décision d'erreur
fondamentale mais c'est aussi une
décision qui pourrait avoir été prise
justement pour augmenter le nombre de
nouvelles recrues sur un seul
quinquennat alors on va pas vous
demander le niveau en maths en tout cas
ces informations sur une baisse du
niveau de recrutement et de formation de
la police nationale sont elles
surprenante pour vous alors non c'est
pas surprenant en soi parce que cette
enquête ait fait écho à d'autres que
nous avons menées depuis devise 17 en
novembre 2010 est par exemple on avait
interrogé des policiers de la mission
qui s'appelle qui s'appelait du moins du
soc
c'est à dire la mission vigipirate de la
police les jeunes policiers nous avait
dit qu'il manquait d'expérience
notamment pour agir face au phénomène
des tueries de masse qui savaient pas
toujours bien servir dans le matériel
notamment le débat mystique et puis en
en juin je le croise la verte eirin
jessica powell ancien secrétaire général
de l'unsa police qui m'avait confié que
le mystère l'intérieur est en
difficultés pour recruter et qui
n'étaient même des gros moyens sur la
table pour lancer des campagnes
publicitaires dans ce sens
l'effet de d'engouement pour le métier
de la part des jeunes qui a été bien
bien remarqué en 2015 après les
attentats il est un rebond b1 ensuite en
2020 on a interrogé informateur de la
police qui nous a expliqué que certains
entraînements notamment le physique
n'était plus vraiment encouragée en
police nationale parce que ces aspects
là la formation continue ne sont pas
obligatoires ce qui fait que certains
patrons police sévère des dvd aux gardes
et ne vois pas vraiment l'intérêt de se
priver de personnel sur le terrain nos
fonctionnaires pour des entraînements
qui leur rapporte rien en termes de
primes de résultat exceptionnel c'est
parfois jusqu'à un doublement du salaire
enfin ma mère les hauts gradés
privilégier les donc des séances de tir
plutôt que par exemple le self défense
l'exercice physique tout simplement
courir faire des bonds pas c'est un peu
ce que nous avait expliqué ce formateur
c'est qu'il manque un peu de
physiquement actuellement
mais justement justement c'est bien un
problème est ce que ce genre de logique
purement administrative elle a peut-être
menées au débat sur la clé
d'étranglement et à une mauvaise
maîtrise des techniques d'intervention
notamment vainqueur de la sphère show
via qui est maintenant qu'il ya une
manifestation encore hier justement pour
marquer ce triste anniversaire merci
beaucoup antoine boitel je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste web sur rt france